افادت مراسلته الجزيره في شرق اوكرانيا ان
منطقه كي اف سي في مدينه دونيت تعرضت لقصف
صاروخيا من الجانب الاوكراني صباح اليوم
وقالت السلطات المحليه ان القصف او قاعه
قتلى وجرحى في صفوف المدنيين والحق اضرارا
بمبالغ سكنيه واضافت السلطات وان احد
الصواريخ اصاب مركزا للشرطه وكان مركز
مدينه
تعرض امس الخميس لقصف صاروخيا كثيب او قاع
قتيلين احدهما من رجال الشرطه المحليه
وادى الاحتراق عدد من السيارات
وقالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان وحداتها
احبطت محاولات القوات الاوكرانيه الهجوم
على مناطق في جنوب مقاطعه دونيت
لواء المدفعيه الاربعين التابعه للقوات
الاوكرانيه حيث تدمر موقعان لاطلاق
الصواريخ جراند في ميخائيل
ثلاثه مستودعات للصواريخ والمدفعيه وذخائر
القوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه زاكولوجيا وفي
جمهوريه دنيا 29
[موسيقى]